my name
is sebastian miailov and i
bring to you along with the world
champion
magnus carson the wonderful app tactics
frenzy sold millions of unique
high quality and entertaining chess
puzzles
that have all been quality checked by
strong
grandmasters like even with the camera
and good stuff song become a member
today
and compete for monthly prizes
sponsored by chessable just24
magnus trainer and of course king
himself magnus carson
we have made sure that no matter how
good you are at chess
you can enjoy this app and get
the challenge of your life alireza aruja
alexander grishik sergey karjakin among
a lot of the lead players they all love
the app
and i can assure you you will as well
download the app today and become a
chess
champion
[Music]
hello everybody today i'm going to solve
some tactics in
tactics frenzy my name is andreas frisia
and let's see
it is going to be fun i think
so let's start with the random
so okay cool for
already i'm struggling and nice
i'm gaining time by solving these
tactics i think
so that is good so it takes 27
and takes so this is your
stream made um
it is actually not okay i could take and
think of sound
let's go b7 i guess
but then but then he might take on c5
mr queen so this is not easy actually
so maybe i'll have to give a check on g7
first because if kinky seeks queen g8
yeah takes mp7
mcqueen um here
of course it should be knight c7 i think
and knight takes a8
nice um here i go knight c6
king d6 take the bishop and knight f7
it's winning okay so
here i could go so the bishop on d7 i'm
bishop on b2 so rook a2
and rook b2 and i take the shot
nice okay this is making one
this is the rook it is getting easier
for some reason
not sure why um
okay thanks this is surprising
okay this is making one this could be
three
here i could go bishop f7 right
yeah i'm crunchy okay
i should be okay maybe knight f3 is very
nice
so both works here
queen g5 on queen g6 both works okay
um let's give a check and takes
okay this is a nice mate
so we go
d4 here and take on e3
let's go g5
f6 and take the queen
okay here let's go
h5 and finish it made
these tactics are not easy for sure
i don't know if it is getting gonna get
harder
the next ones i think it is 95 right and
g3 i could take
hopefully it is going to be harder
um this one is just a knight
okay i could take the rooks here
i have this fork okay this is pin the
queen
here okay this one i should be
careful maybe not this is just
takes and
just knife the fun i guess
nice queen c5 check
c7 um
okay what should i do here i could go
knight b4 knight c2 to
fork the rooks but
probably this is what i should actually
yeah
okay this i'm feeling this is getting
harder
i'm not sure like this is not clear now
queen okay i think this is just knight
fg7
oh it was wrong okay
okay that was strange thanks
um
okay this one is check right
and take the rook
[Music]
okay
can i go queen each four minutes
yes okay
so i could take the bishop here and take
the rook
king d5 king c5ab
um
what can i do here queen is seven
should i take the rook here on f6 and go
knight g6 check
that looks much better for white but
maybe there is a glowing
thing here probably it's not
okay yeah so bishop
for real i should continue here
this is strange i have many rooms that
is winning
like rook g6 95 okay my time is ticking
here
okay now i could i should be
faster actually
[Music]
okay this is nice b3
what can i do rook h3 equals h5
if i take on f7 he takes if i take on h7
it seems very
slow but maybe it is the solution
who knows
um i cannot see it
what should i do
oh should i just i should take here and
click on f7 wow
that was weird
okay these are getting harder
[Music]
wow this was surprising suddenly it got
much
more difficult
[Music]
okay nice nice these these are
insane i was not expecting it
um okay nice
[Music]
oh my god should i just go rookie six
yeah it was right i was not even
expecting to be right
oh it was wrong
[Music]
review the mistakes maybe i should
review the mistakes
best streak 28 i don't know if what is
the top streak
toughest streak in the side probably it
is much higher probably it is around
i don't know 50 60 something
okay this one i should go on oh bye
okay let's play again let's do it one
more time
okay let's go f4 and take on d4
takes bishop f3 king takes e7
and f6 from mate
okay now i know how is this work how
does this work
it is it was very surprising that
suddenly it got
very hard with a very little time
so i have to do this faster than the
first ones
so queen d5 made
so rook f6 g8 queen
[Music]
um okay this one i have to go
[Music]
what
oh it is black to move okay
look ahead i wanted to give a check with
the rook it was not letting me
eight um
[Music]
i have many moves here now
i have so many moves but maybe there is
some
very nice ones here like i'm thinking
about queen d5 here but
maybe it doesn't work
um 25
okay 25 is right wow
27 thanks nice okay
okay this was easy okay now it could do
okay it should be rook d5 but bishop d5
is also
or not bishop c2 bishop d5 is not
possible
okay this one is the paint shop
what is this
what so okay i'm gonna trust my
intuition
and go here i
think okay nice so this one is taking a
look the one i have to be faster
so it takes check hopefully i could do
better than 28
28 is kind of embarrassing
i have a feeling maybe it is not
[Music]
but probably it is um
okay i have to take and look we need to
index it knight takes
it of course this is meeting one
this is not medium one
what can i do queen g8 doesn't work
i have a feeling it should be some slow
move here
so i'm not sure each one
like
i don't know
i have no idea what is this
oh my god
bishop e5 doesn't work bishop h6
bishop h6 is insane if it is right
move here because we should have six
rook of eight i don't see it
let's try the show h6 i don't know if it
is good
okay nice special e6 these are insane
okay tough tough very tough you need
seven let's get so easy at least
these are tough
okay but it is fun at the same time of
course
it's always too good always good to be
challenged
i have think this is my this is gonna be
the last puzzle
i'm not going to get this one
yeah of course it was around bishop
seven these are hard
especially with the time ticking he's
kind of
freaking
okay let's click on these three i'm
going to give one
[Music]
and
nice i'm getting some right
um get me to 28 at least
five okay we are gaining some time with
these easy puzzles it's nice
before
should be this right
i can't
i'm going to take this one and take on
c8
take on g6 second c7
why i am not gaining any streak maybe it
is finished over here
i don't know
is it finished already i don't know
like okay take on a6 but these puzzles
are very
easy okay now
i have to do more to see how it works
okay it was wrong um
this was very fun i'm going to do it
more
of course maybe of the video
but it is a it is a very fun thing and
i really recommend it because these
puzzles were
also good for the maybe a little
later plays also it was very good for me
as you saw
i couldn't get all of them so
thanks for watching and see you guys
[Music]
you